you have probably been listening to what
alex sharma has been saying do you
believe him that he's got the makings of
a deal
i think he's doing his best but i think
his efforts at international diplomacy
are being entirely undermined by
government actions at home as you
pointed to in your questioning yourself
the first rule of diplomacy is to walk
your talk and yet both on the finance
for climate and on the emissions
reductions this government is doing the
opposite it is absolutely outrageous
that the government has cut our own aid
budget by four billion pounds and yet
thinks it has the moral authority to
lecture other countries about increasing
their climate finance we are in no
position to do that when we have slashed
our own aid budget and when it comes to
emission cuts if you look at what
government is actually doing we are way
off track in terms of meeting our own
climate targets the committee on climate
change the government's independent
advisors says that we keep blundering
into high carbon choices you've got the
cumbria coal mine that you mentioned
you've got a new oil field being planned
uh the cambo oil filled off shetland
you've got a 27 billion pound road
building plan you've got airport
expansion you've got the failure to put
in place any kind of home insulation
program the list goes on and on so in
terms of walking the talk i'm afraid
that alok sharma's very good efforts i'm
sure at diplomacy are being cut off at
the knees by the prime minister
one of the striking things that um mr
sharma
told us is that he has not yet got
an rsvp yes from the chinese president
xi jinping
do you think that a deal that is
sustainable can be struck without his
presence
i think that's almost impossible to
envisage no it is absolutely essential
that china is there and that's why i am
deeply concerned about this new
so-called orcas deal because we have
just
enraged the chinese even more if cop 26
if this climate talks these u.n climate
talks are our top diplomatic priority
then everything else should be taking
second place to that so i'm deeply
worried about relations with china i'm
also deeply worried about relations with
the developing world because they too
have the ability to walk away from these
talks if they choose to they were
promised a hundred billion dollars a
year by 2020 they were promised that
right back in 2009 and we still haven't
delivered we are 20 billion short of
that not only that but just two percent
of some countries in africa have been
fully vaccinated so when it comes to
equality we are absolutely okay and
raging as well the developing world
losing their trust as well as losing the
trust of countries like china
let's
let's talk about opinion
at home um
i don't know if you were in invited to
the protests uh around the m25 uh or if
you were free but had you been invited
and been free would you have been out
there blocking the road
well trevor i have a proud history of
taking non-violent direct action as does
the green party and we do believe that
it is legitimate when other forms of of
trying to raise issues with the
government have failed as long as it is
non-violent then i think we need to
understand why protesters have taken
this extreme action you know ban ki-moon
the former u.n general secretary has
said this is an emergency and in
emergency situations we need to take
emergency action i believe that's what
those protesters were doing um it is a
really difficult thing to try to capture
on a mild september sunday the fact that
we are facing an existential threat to
life on earth that feels a very odd
thing to say over your breakfast but
that is what we are facing when it comes
to the demands of those protesters they
want the government to insulate britain
i cannot think of a more reasonable
demand it's a it's a triple win it would
get our fuel bills down it would create
hundreds of thousands of jobs in every
part of the country it would get our
climate emissions down too why has the
government failed to do that
so so um i'm taking that as a yes and
that you think it's reasonable
for this cause
to stop people going to work
particularly those people who can't work
from home do you think that's okay and
you would have been i think it is
i think it is unreasonable for this
government to have no no let's just
stick with the protest itself i know
your view about the government
you think it's reasonable for them to
have done what they did
i'm saying that their demands are
reasonable and i'm no well i'm asking
about what they did
it is reasonable to take emergency
action and that's what they were doing
the government has failed to put in
place any kind of um
insulation program first of all we had
the green deal that completely failed it
had interest rates of eight percent so
if people were taking loans to insulate
their homes that would have cost them a
fortune then we had the green homes
grant that has collapsed in absolute
chaos there is no program to keep
people's homes warm in the meantime
what's happening is that people are
dying prematurely every year from fuel
poverty what's happening is that around
15
of our emissions in the uk are coming
from our leaky housing stock what is
unreasonable is the fact that the
government sets its face against a set
of policies that will get our emissions
down that will get jobs up that will get
people's fuel bills down and would
address some of the issues you were
talking to alok about right at the start
of this conversation which was about
prices as well i fully understand your
point about what you regard as a
government iniquities but uh just to be
absolutely clear coming to the end now
you think this was a perfectly
reasonable action
uh if they send you an invitation next
time you will be saying yeah i'll come
and i will block the m25
i am saying that in extreme situations
it is reasonable to take extreme actions
and that is what has driven these
protesters to do that personally i
prefer to take action where it is closer
to the target of that action so that
might be downing street it might be the
treasury but i fully understand why
protesters have felt driven to do
something more dramatic than that
because government has been ignoring all
of those kinds of actions for many many
years we face an existential crisis an
emergency and we need to take emergency
action now